dominique issermann bonsoir
leonard cohen ce soir là tu fais quoi
paris
c'était fermé prochaine avec parmi les
causes encore dominique issermann oui
oui des voix lorsque le clip qu'on vient
de voir c'était un trip 2 minutes estime
déjà que s'appeler dance to develop et
celui là il va s'appeler comment alors
est ce que tu crois tu étais à une
certaine époque un phénomène de société
énorme parfait livres par tf1 ce disque
est ce que tu crois qu'aujourd'hui
encore quelque chose à apporter au monde
où est ce que tu fais ça peut payer des
impôts
autant que je sache je trouve toujours
chanteur ouais tu continues je comptais
bien dès les prochains 10 heures quand
la fin janvier en janvier
ils s'appellent comme le clip non c'est
un humain amis ont menacé bien tout
était faux sur sa superbe
moi j'ai écouté merci à s'aimer
merci
ça
alors il ya quoi y'a grain
vingt ans
- au moins
avec john baez dylan peter paul and mary
vous avez voulait changer le monde
est ce que le monde a changé
pas beaucoup nous invoquons non
combien de temps
et alors il a changé un canard ouais moi
je trouve ce disque est un peu différent
de l'autre et ses îles et plus
plus positif même plus
on y est la musique est peut-être plus
percutante
je trouve ça fun évidemment c'est
toujours
comité avec les autres disent mais je
trouve qu'une petite rupture ce
disque-là par rapport à ceux d'avant est
une espèce d'énergie
d'optimisme comme ça qui est
4 est beau dans les
las pour eux dans l'énergie les renard
est ce que tu trouves ton énergie
[Musique]
je n'ai jamais peur d'eux
et là tu as
53 quel effet ça fait de moi je suis
vieux mais j'ai 38 ans ces pages jaunes
non il paraît que tu veux jamais appelé
les femmes baby c'est vrai tu appelles
baby une sorte de mini qui sert
magnificence des techniques issermann
non taipei qui veut jamais un téléphone
mobile
l'évolution en avant mais dans la vie
c'est possible dans la vie non c'est pas
possible j'ai toujours des maisons grâce
à hydra je le garde
je la garde toujours mais
je serais pas là
qu'est ce que tu penses que tu vas
laisser de plus important quel morceau
de musique qu'elle l'est plus je pense
que c'est pas du tout important
6 6 1
je ne peux pas choisir un morceau s'il
ya quelque chose d'important
est ce que tu crois qu est ce que tu vas
laisser de plus important c'est ce qui
est le plus connu par la mort je pense
que c'est donc suzanne que tu vas
laisser le plus important probable et
beautiful dix ans peut-être
ce pas mal et un prochain disque elle
prochain d'esker
alors toi qu'est ce que tu sais bien
je continue à faire les photos mawet et
partent révèle que des noces du somalie
oui allez wacquez la pause et encore
parce que d'habitude il paraît que tu
veux pas tellement fait des photos
soigneusement des ligues soit tu penses
que ça suffit qu'elle soit dans les
magazines pour des pivots cours du
rédactionnel cela s'était renseigné
c'est vrai j'aime bien le support de la
presse aime bien français qu'une photo
va dans un bien travaillé pour la page
du journal et que savoir que ce support
est éphémère et disparaît ce travail et
pour un support comme un mur de galeries
par exemple sont assurées soyez jamais
osé faire une exposition
parce que c'est quelque chose qui doit
rester qui est permanent un tirage qu'on
doit vendre
la peur mais là je me suis décidé
comment ça s'est passé j'avais fait un
travail de publicité en fait avec des
avec des japonais avec anwar et c'était
un calendrier de nus et puis en le
faisant j'ai pensé qu' on n'avait pas
vraiment
qu'est ce qu'on aurait pu faire dans
château cette maison là si tu me
retourner pendant
trois fois et d après midi mais j'ai
fait d'autres photos et qui sait après
les contacts se sont accumulés puma fait
les tirages et puis après un éditeur
schirmer mosel a vu les photos il a
proposé de faire un livre s'enchaîner
comme ça ça s'appelle anne roy
j'ai cherché un terme à cette facilité
c'est pas c'est l'histoire d'une fille
avec un bras dans un château
c'est en fait c'est un portrait de l'âme
sale temps de sade valoir sur vie ratée
de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais 1 pouces bleus